[Musik]
SALLY: Neben dir sehe ich echt klein aus.
AARON: Nein, warte. Ich kann es machen, dass du dich normal fühlst.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute habe ich einen Praktikanten an meiner Seite,
[Jubel] der heute vielleicht die Konditorausbildung beenden wird.
AARON: [Doing] Ja, hallo. Ich bin da.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich hatte ja einen Back-Shop,
aber ich habe immer nur aufgebacken, d.h. in den Ofen rein,
nach 10 Minuten mit Wasser sprühen und dann rausnehmen.
SALLY: Ja, so alte Sachen wieder frisch machen.
AARON: Ja, genau. [Sally lacht]
Es gibt auch Dauergebäck, das man 1 Woche verkaufen kann.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Okay, also Aaron wird mir heute tatkräftig zur Seite stehen.
Wir backen heute eine Tiramisu Tarte.
[Grillengeräusche]
AARON: Ja.
SALLY: Wir machen erst einmal einen Mürbeteig. Weißt du, was das ist?
AARON: [Lacht] Nein.
SALLY: Aus Mürbeteig macht man z.B. auch Kekse, Plätzchen und Keksteig.
[Modemgeräusche]
Hast du schon einmal Kekse gebacken?
AARON: Da ist Butter. [Beide lachen]
Doch, mit Papa früher immer als Kind.
SALLY: Ja, gell?
AARON: Zu Weihnachten.
SALLY: So ein Mürbeteig besteht eigentlich nur aus 3 Zutaten
- so ein 1-2-3-Teig: 1 Teil Zucker, 2 Teile Butter, 3 Teile Mehl.
Eigelb kommt noch zur Bindung dazu, Vanille und Salz für den Geschmack.
[Modemgeräusche; Sallys Stimme verblasst immer mehr]
AARON: Salz auch noch? [Sally bejaht] Okay.
SALLY: Hebt immer den süßen Geschmack.
Wir stellen immer am Anfang meine Zutaten vor.
Also erstmal hier die Zutaten für den Mürbeteig.
Für den Mürbeteig brauchen wir 100 g Zucker, 200 g kalte Butter,
300 g Mehl, etwas Vanilleextrakt, 2 Eigelbe und 1 Prise Salz.
AARON: Redest du in deinen Videos eigentlich auch manchmal
mit deinen Leuten hinter der Kamera? [Sally bejaht]
Also, Josh, komm mal ran und filme hier.
JOSH: Das macht Murat immer.
SALLY: Also wir Zwei machen das schon gedanklich.
AARON: Ah, okay.
SALLY: Ich habe mir gedacht,
wir machen das heute einmal ohne Küchenmaschine,
denn ich denke, du hast bestimmt keine Küchenmaschine
und du willst bestimmt zu Hause die Tarte nachbacken. [Aaron bejaht]
Deswegen machen wir heute alles…
AARON: Gibt’s eine Teig-Küchenmaschine?
SALLY: Ja, klar: KitchenAid, Kenwood, …
Also ihr könnt es jetzt mit dem Knethaken, dem Handrührgerät,
der Küchenmaschine mit dem Flachrührer, dem Mixer
oder den Händen zubereiten – wir machen es heute mit den Händen.
AARON: Dann brauche ich eine Schüssel.
SALLY: Wir machen das direkt hier. Erst einmal Mehl.
Der Mürbeteig wurde früher auch Hackteig genannt,
weil man den mit dem Messer so zerhackt hat.
AARON: Jetzt hast du mir die Info genommen, die ich wusste.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Ich klaue mir einmal kurz 1 Prise Salz bei dir.
AARON: Du machst da jetzt schon Salz?
SALLY: Ja klar!
Wir backen heute die Tarte gleichzeitig.
Also Aaron lernt tatsächlich direkt am ersten Tag gleich mit.
AARON: Ich habe schon so viel gelernt! [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Zucker rein.
AARON: Ja. Zucker rein.
SALLY: Sehr gut! Jetzt machst du so eine kleine Mulde.
AARON: Einen Vulkan, okay. Und da mache ich das Ei rein.
SALLY: Erst einmal die Butter.
AARON: Ach so. Oh, dann muss es ja eine große Mulde sein.
SALLY: Ja. Während die Hände noch sauber sind,
auch schon einmal Vanilleextrakt.
AARON: Wie viel Vanilleextrakt nimmt man denn immer?
SALLY: 1/2 – 1 TL. Das ist jetzt schon ziemlich aufgebraucht, aber…
AARON: Ich brauche neues. Wo kriege ich das denn her?!
[Sally lacht]
Gehe ich doch einmal direkt zu Lidl, weil Lidl lohnt sich!
Ist das 1 TL?
SALLY: Ja, das reicht schon.
AARON: Okay.
SALLY: Jetzt kann man, wie gesagt,
entweder ein Messer oder eine Teigkarte nehmen.
Da schneidet man sich auch nicht daran.
Deswegen ist sie ganz praktisch.
Dann kannst du jetzt die Butterstückchen zerhacken.
Bei Mürbeteig ist es wichtig, dass er kalt bleiben muss.
Deswegen gehen wir jetzt nicht mit den Fingern ran,
sondern wir zerhacken den Teig.
AARON: Ach so, weil die Finger ihn erwärmen würden.
SALLY: Genau, und der Teig soll kalt bleiben,
damit der Keksteig schön knusprig und mürbe bleibt.
[Musik]
Immer so ein bisschen Mehl darauf und dann weiter.
AARON: Was hast du eigentlich mit Kai gemacht?
SALLY: Mit Kai? Eine Cookie Torte.
Er hat immer wieder genascht.
AARON: Kai Pflaume? [Sally bejaht]
[Musik]
SALLY: So, die Eigelbe hinein.
Wenn du dann so weit bist, mit den Händen kurz nachhelfen,
aber so, dass der Teig nicht warm wird.
AARON: Der riecht voll lecker! Ist das deine?
Der riecht auf jeden Fall richtig gut!
SALLY: Nach Vanille.
AARON: Stimmt. Mega!
[Musik]
SALLY: Dann wird er kaltgestellt.
AARON: Warum ist denn deiner… ?
SALLY: Der braucht jetzt nur ein bisschen Handwärme, so ein bisschen…
AARON: Aber deiner ist schon so schön gelb.
SALLY: Ja, das sind die Eigelbe.
AARON: Wie meine Zähne.
SALLY: Dann muss man ihn 1 Stunde kaltstellen.
Damit er schnell kühlt, drücke ich ihn immer flach.
Und?
AARON: Voll lecker.
SALLY: Gell? Keksteig ist immer lecker.
AARON: Besser als das Eigelb, das ich gerade getrunken habe.
SALLY: Eiweiß.
AARON: Eiweiß, meine ich ja!
SALLY: Oh, das war schon eine…
AARON: Aber… Ey, das ist…
SALLY: Das ist aber voll gut.
Dann sehe jetzt, wie es die Menschen zu Hause machen
AARON: Was muss ich denn noch machen? Ich fühle…
JUTTA: Kneten!
SALLY: Zeig mal!
AARON: Aber ich… doll kneten?
SALLY: Knete mal so ein bisschen dem Handballen
- nicht mit den Fingern, sondern Handballen.
AARON: Ich habe ja 3 Monate Masseur gelernt
- Masseur und medizinischer Bademeister. Dann habe ich abgebrochen.
SALLY: Warum?
JUTTA: [Lacht] Ich habe es im Podcast gehört.
AARON: Ich sage mal so…
JUTTA: Weil er die Hitze nicht sehen wollte. [Lacht]
SALLY: Du hast Aarons Podcast gehört? [Jutta bejaht]
[Sally lacht]
AARON: Jutta ist nämlich die Beste hier im Team!
Eine Massage startet meistens bei der Analfalte,
eh… Maurer-Dekolletee. Ich sage mal so:
Leider massiert man in der Lehre
und auch im Krankenwesen selten eine Sally oder einen Aaron,
sondern dann doch eher die Oma und den Opa.
Das war mir vorher so nicht bewusst.
[Beide lachen]
Dann habe ich mitgekriegt, ich kann gut mit ihnen reden,
aber nicht so gut massieren.
Deswegen habe ich dann Einzelhandelskaufmann gelernt.
SALLY: Jutta, ich feiere dich! Ich feiere dich, Jutta!
AARON: Guck mal, jetzt habt ihr doch schon…
SALLY: Zeig mal! Ja, sieht doch gut aus.
AARON: Juttas Tipp war Gold wert.
SALLY: Siehst du?
Genau, jetzt säuberst du noch die Matte, alle Zutaten noch rein.
AARON: Die Matte ist mega!
Und jetzt mache ich jetzt wieder alles drauf?
SALLY: Genau. Immer mehr mit dem Handballen, nicht mit den Fingern.
AARON: Okay.
SALLY: Das schont auch so ein bisschen die Gelenke,
tut dann auch nicht weh, weil wenn man jeden Tag backt,
Fondant und Mürbeteig knetet - das geht schon…
AARON: Wie heißt es:
Fondant oder Fondant (französische vs. deutsche Aussprache)?
SALLY: Fondant eigentlich (französische Aussprache).
Franzosen sagen Fondant, die anderen sagen Fondent.
AARON: Aber guck mal, jetzt ist hier wieder alles…
SALLY: Nimmst du auch noch mit rein – das geht schon noch rein
Der braucht nur so ein bisschen Zuneigung, so ein bisschen.
Bist du schon aus der Puste?
AARON: [Lacht] Anstrengend!
Aber ich ärgere mich auch, weil es bei dir so…
Klar, dass du besser bist, aber dass ich so viel schlechter bin…
Und es geht jetzt nur ums Kneten.
Es geht ja jetzt nicht um Rechnen oder so.
SALLY: Mürbeteig herstellen ist schon Back-Basic.
AARON: Das ist jetzt nur der Boden am Ende, oder? [Sally bejaht]
Was machen wir obendrauf?
SALLY: Darauf kommt eine Mascarpone-Creme, Kaffee-Creme…
Du trinkst keinen Kaffee. Magst du auch keinen Kaffeegeschmack?
AARON: Nein.
SALLY: Okay, dann lassen wir ihn bei dir weg.
AARON: Gibt’s heiße Schoki…? [Sally bejaht]
Geschmack? Den nehme ich!
Guck mal, es geht immer noch nicht ab.
SALLY: Doch, sieht gut aus. Komm!
AARON: Ich drücke es immer platt, weil das jetzt kühlen muss
und dann geht das besser. So mache ich das immer.
SALLY: Ich finde, man sieht keinen Unterschied.
AARON: Ich finde auch nicht.
SALLY: Ja, jetzt hole ich hier noch den Deckel heraus.
Vorsicht, Schienbein!
Einmal so, einmal so. Dann machen wir jetzt hier kurz sauber
und kühlen den Teig für 1 Stunde.
[Musik und Uhr]
Der Mürbeteig ist jetzt kalt. Jetzt geht es mit der Tarte weiter.
Die Tarte bekommt ja eine schöne Füllung
- bei mir eine Kaffee-, bei dir eine heiße Schokoladenfüllung.
AARON: Sehr gut!
SALLY: Dafür nehmen wir 50 g weiche Butter, 100 g Zucker, 2 Eier,
250 g Quark, 20 g Stärke, 1 EL Kakao
- genau, du nimmst 100 ml Milch, ich nehme 100 ml Kaffee -,
und bei dir noch zum Verfeinern Tonka Wonka bzw. Tonkabohnenpaste.
Passt, oder?
Bei meinen Zuschauern ist es auch so:
Ich mache oft bzw. gern etwas mit Kaffee
und die fragen mich immer: Was ist die Alternative?
Als Alternative könnt ihr immer heiße Schokolade oder Kakao nehmen.
AARON: Ja, sehr gut!
Ich habe noch nie mit so einem Ding gearbeitet, jetzt wirklich ehrlich!
SALLY: Jetzt machst du mich schwach. Noch nie ein Handrührgerät?
AARON: Ich habe auch 2 linke Hände.
Ich kann auch nicht mit einer Bohrmaschine und so arbeiten.
SALLY: Echt jetzt?
AARON: Ach so, das geht vorwärts und rückwärts?
SALLY: Und wenn du später einmal Haus, Kind, Kegel…?
AARON: Muss die Frau das können. Nein, nein.
Das muss ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil sie die Frau ist,
sondern weil ich das nicht kann!
SALLY: [Leicht verwundert] Gut.
AARON: Ich kann dafür Windeln wechseln. Also…
SALLY: Ja? Kannst du? Schaffst du?
AARON: Würde ich als Alternative anbieten, weil ich nicht…
SALLY: Wir können es ja bei so einer Puppe einmal ausprobieren.
Okay, am besten erst einschalten, wenn es drin ist.
AARON: Okay, was mache ich jetzt?
SALLY: [Lacht] Die Butter hier rein. Da ist ein Teigschaber.
AARON: Teigschaber… Was ist das?
SALLY: Eine Löffelablage, dass dein Arbeitsplatz sauber bleibt.
Ist nicht von mir, ist von einem Partner.
AARON: Ach so, nein, ich finde… Was es alles gibt.
Darauf kommt man nicht! Ich esse ja sonst nur. Okay, ist drin.
SALLY: Gut, dann Zucker rein
und erst einschalten, wenn du das Rührgerät reingesteckt hast.
[Handrührgerät; Sally lacht]
AARON: Höchste Stufe.
SALLY: [Lacht] Vollgas!
AARON: Auf 5? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Langsam starten wegen dem Zucker.
AARON: Wie langsam starten?
[Musik]
SALLY: Dann gibst du Eier dazu – eins nach dem anderen.
Also 1 Ei reinflutschen lassen, einrühren und dann das nächste.
[Handrührgerät]
Es wird jetzt so eine Käsekuchenmasse.
AARON: Ah, und jetzt das andere? [Sally stimmt zu]
Ich kann ehrlich sagen: Wenn so alles vorbereitet wird,
man schöne Arbeitsmaterialien hat, macht Backen richtig Spaß!
[Musik]
SALLY: Dann können jetzt alle anderen Zutaten hinein.
AARON: Was mache ich hiermit? Ach so, den kann man so abstellen.
SALLY: Ich stelle den so hin, ja.
[Beide lachen]
Quark, Speisestärke, bei mir der Kaffee…
AARON: Ach gleich jetzt alles rein? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: … und Kakao.
Dann mit dem Rühren langsam anfangen,
denn da kann es passieren, dass etwas herausspritzt.
AARON: Ah, okay.
[Handrührgerät]
SALLY: Ups.
AARON: Passiert!
[Handrührgerät]
SALLY: Steck‘ es lieber ganz rein.
AARON: Ja. [Sally lacht]
Hey…
SALLY: Macht Spaß, oder?
AARON: Ja, es ist ganz schön…
Das letzte Mal, als ich mit so viel weißem Zeug zu tun hatte,
war ich auf einer anderen Party.
[Musik]
SALLY: Gut, dann stellen wir es zur Seite, machen kurz sauber
und holen den Teig zum Ausrollen.
AARON: Wie?
SALLY: Der Teig muss doch ausgerollt werden und kommt in Form.
AARON: Mmh!
SALLY: Schmeckt gut?
AARON: War noch ein bisschen viel Butter drauf. Aber okay…
SALLY: [Lacht] Das war auch der Butterlöffel.
AARON: Sehr gut.
SALLY: Sehr schön.
AARON: Richtig gut.
SALLY: Es ist immer gut, wenn man direkt probiert. [Aaron bejaht]
Ich mache es auch zum ersten Mal und hab einfach das Rezept so…
AARON: Machst du Plastik auch sauber?
SALLY: … in der Theorie nur zusammengerührt.
AARON: Ist das jetzt… Ach dafür, dass ich…
SALLY: Nein.
AARON: Weil ich zu dumm zum Ausrollen bin,
kriege ich wieder die Kinderhilfe. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Das ist die Kinderunterstützung.
AARON: Wirklich? Das heißt, du drehst da auf, ja?
SALLY: Ja. Da kommt jetzt der Ring rein.
[Beide lachen]
AARON: Also Schwimmflügel. Du brauchst sie nicht? [Sally verneint]
Warum nicht?
SALLY: Weil ich’s kann. [Hupgeräusch]
Aber ich nehme sie auch oft.
AARON: Ja, ja! Das ist immer so diese:
Ich brauche es auch, aber heute nicht, weil ich nicht dumm bin!
[Beide lachen]
So, okay. Habe ich.
SALLY: Gut. Das ist die Tarte-Form. Da kommt unser Kuchen rein.
Jetzt nehmen wir ein bisschen Mehl. Wo ist eigentlich unser Teig?
Haben wir den schon draußen? [Aaron verneint]
Nein, oder?
AARON: Wo ist denn der Teig?
SALLY: Ich hole ihn.
AARON: Das war meiner.
SALLY: Ich weiß, der ist so schön.
AARON: Ey nein, das war deiner. Ich finde meinen besser.
SALLY: Sieht gut aus.
AARON: Und jetzt?
SALLY: Jetzt herausholen.
AARON: Wie? Dann geht der schon wieder kaputt.
SALLY: Den müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen kneten.
Der muss ein bisschen warm werden, dass wir ihn ausrollen können.
Warte, ich gebe dir eine Hilfe.
AARON: Gibt’s für alles Hilfen? [Sally lacht]
Was ist das?
SALLY: Jetzt kannst du ihn so herausholen. Eine Teigkarte.
AARON: Oder Scheibenkratzer.
SALLY: Habe ich auch schon im Winter gemacht, mit der gezackten.
AARON: Fertig! Na ja, okay.
Ja, habe ich, habe ich, habe ich, habe ich.
SALLY: Jetzt ein bisschen kneten.
Das ist schon der anstrengende Part, einen kalten Teig zu kneten.
Eigentlich müsste ich schon solche Oberarme haben,
habe ich aber nicht.
AARON: Ja, müsstest du.
SALLY: Wie so eine italienische Omi.
Schon ein harter Job. [Aaron stimmt zu]
Sowas mache ich dreifach parallel an einem Tag.
AARON: Wissen das die Zuschauer,
dass wir mehrere Videos auf einmal drehen?
SALLY: Nein.
[Musik]
AARON: Ich finde es ja so verrückt,
dass du so viele Videos auf einmal drehen kannst, weil ich im Kopf
bei der Pizza bin, die wir auch machen.
Jetzt muss ich hier wieder auf einmal Kuchen zaubern.
SALLY: Ja, so überbrücke ich immer die Wartezeit, die Kühlzeit…
AARON: Hast du das schon immer gemacht
und standest du früher immer so eine Stunde rum und dachtest…
Ich könnte in der Zeit ein anderes Video drehen.
SALLY: Nein, ich war schon immer auf Zeitersparnis.
Oder in der Zeit machst du den Haushalt.
AARON: [Singend] Das bisschen Haushalt
BEIDE: [Singend] macht sich von allein.
SALLY: Wenn er dann so schön rund ist…
AARON: Rund – okay.
SALLY: Ich hole hier einmal ein Backtrennspray heraus.
Vorsicht, dein Bein.
AARON: Oh ja, Tschuldigung.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Du glaubst, ich hab’s nicht gemerkt, oder?
AARON: Ich dachte, die sehen sehr ähnlich aus.
Könntest du mir nochmal Mehl darauf machen?
SALLY: Ja klar!
AARON: Bitte? Danke!
Deiner riecht auch gut. Nein, nimm mal deinen.
Ich will meinen haben.
SALLY: Ja? [Aaron bejaht] Okay.
AARON: Einmal von deinem kauen.
SALLY: Jetzt arbeiten wir mit wenig Mehl, ja? Ein bisschen hier.
Und versuchen den Teig rund auszurollen. Die Form ist 25 cm groß.
Du brauchst jetzt ungefähr 30 cm.
AARON: Ach, und deswegen sind hier die Zentimeterangaben.
Voll pfiffig. [Sally stimmt zu]
Ich brauche noch ein bisschen Mehl, aber nur ein bisschen oben?
SALLY: Ich gebe es einmal hier hin.
AARON: Danke!
SALLY: Damit der gleichmäßig wird,
sind bei dir diese 5 mm-Ringe drauf.
AARON: Wie?
SALLY: Dann wird er genau 5 mm dick.
Jetzt rollst du ein bisschen und drehst ihn,
damit er auch schön rund wird.
AARON: Ich kann auch einfach das Holz hier nehmen, oder?
SALLY: Ja, aber wenn du das hier drehst, dann klebt er auch nicht.
Also du siehst auch immer, ob noch genug Mehl darunter ist.
AARON: Ich bin jetzt schon bei 25 cm, aber er ist noch nicht rund.
SALLY: Das sind keine 25 cm.
AARON: Hier steht doch 26 cm. [Sally lacht]
Ach so, ha ha ha. Oh, ich brauche mehr Mehl. Ich habe hier Mehl.
Ach so, ja. Ich habe jetzt vergessen:
Nach oben und unten müssen es ja 25 cm sein, [Sally stimmt zu]
in alle Richtungen.
[Musik]
SALLY: Guck mal, das können wir so machen, so darunter schieben.
AARON: Ist das ein Mehl-drunter-schieber?
SALLY: Ja, ein Samurai-Mehl-drunter-schieber.
Okay? Ganz flach.
AARON: Mehl ist das Öl des Backens.
SALLY: Dann nimmst du es hier drauf, nimmst die Form…
AARON: Jetzt hier drauf, aber nicht zu doll, nehme die Form…
SALLY: … und packst ihn da rein.
Wenn es reißt, ist es nicht schlimm. [Lacht]
AARON: Guck mal, der passt perfekt rein,
oder macht man auch solche Flickarbeiten damit? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Wenn er reißt, kannst du Flickarbeiten durchführen.
[Musik]
Dann kannst du hier nämlich mit einer Palette den Rand wegnehmen.
AARON: Warum flicke ich ihn jetzt, sodass ich ihn wieder kaputt mache?
SALLY: Nein, der geht nicht kaputt. Guck, ich mache den Rand perfekt.
[Musik]
AARON: Also ich sehe keinen Unterschied.
SALLY: Ich auch nicht. [Lacht]
Ich finde, der sieht gut aus. [Aaron stimmt zu]
Doch, alles schön.
Jetzt stechen wir ihn so ein bisschen ein, dass er nicht hochbackt.
Ein paar Löcher rein.
AARON: Mit dem kleinen hier? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Diesmal backen wir den Teig gar nicht vor,
sondern füllen ihn direkt,
damit die Käsekuchenmasse auch direkt mitbacken kann.
Ja, ja. Sieht gut aus.
AARON: Jetzt sieht es aus wie ich mit 14.
[Beide lachen]
Das kippen wir da jetzt rein?
SALLY: Ja. Ich hoffe, du hast nicht zu tiefe Löcher gemacht,
dass da jetzt praktisch die Füllung nicht unten…
Geht, oder? Muss ich auch aufpassen.
AARON: Ich bin ein guter Bauarbeiter.
Ich weiß immer meinen Pfusch zu beheben.
SALLY: Dann füllst du es da hinein.
[Musik]
Okay, dann kommt die Tarte jetzt in den Backofen.
Vorsicht, das ist ein Hebeboden.
Also wenn du jetzt unten hältst, nicht hochdrücken,
sonst flutscht alles nach oben.
AARON: Ja, deswegen halte ich so an der Seite.
SALLY: Sehr gut. Komm, ich mache dir einmal den Backofen auf.
AARON: Danke!
SALLY: Vorsicht, Backofen! Nicht verbrennen!
Ich finde, es sieht schön aus. [Aaron stimmt zu]
AARON: Hast du zwei? [Sally bejaht]
Natürlich!
SALLY: Vier!
AARON: Vier? Wo sind denn die anderen?
SALLY: Draußen.
AARON: Ach so. Ich wasche mir die Hände.
Was passiert mit dem Restteig?
SALLY: Wir machen Kekse daraus.
[Musik und Uhr]
Machen wir so einen großen Keks? [Aaron bejaht]
Genau, ein bisschen Mehl darauf.
[Explosion]
AARON: Nein, nein, nein. Wir nehmen das, was wir hier liegen haben.
SALLY: Guck mal, dann mach das so.
AARON: Ja, das war eine gute Idee. Dann mache ich das jetzt.
Ja, jetzt ist gut.
SALLY: Jetzt drücke einfach so den Stempel rein, okay?
AARON: So? [Sally bejaht]
[Geräusche der Anstrengung]
[Beide lachen]
Ach bis zum Boden? Nein?
SALLY: Nein, fast.
[Beide lachen]
AARON: Geil. Es gibt Sally-Keksdruck-Dinger.
SALLY: Das haben die Senioren vom Senioren-Zocken gemacht.
AARON: Ach wirklich?
SALLY: Der Peter wollte nämlich unbedingt Haschkekse backen.
Dann habe ich gesagt: Peter, bei mir gibt es so etwas nicht.
Dann habe ich ihm den Stempel gegeben. Dann war er auch glücklich.
AARON: Muss ich das jetzt so wegmachen? Nein?
SALLY: Nein, warte. Ich gebe dir noch ein Glas zum Ausstechen.
AARON: Ich mache den nochmal. Der hat einen Fehler.
Nein, das war wirklich nicht gut.
SALLY: Und dann ausstechen. Ich kann dir auch einen Ausstecher geben.
Dann rannte die Ela im Kindergarten.
Du kannst dir vorstellen, was sie gesagt hat?
Bei Mama war Senioren Zocken und Mama hat mit denen Haschkekse gebacken.
AARON: Dann gab’s nochmal ein persönliches Gespräch.
Was es alles für Hilfen gibt!
Menschen werden immer fauler. Früher haben wir das alles so gemacht.
SALLY: Ja, guck mal da!
AARON: Was machst du aus den kleinen Bällen?
SALLY: Die kann man auch so… Guck mal!
AARON: Und was ist das jetzt?
SALLY: Das sind auch Kekse.
AARON: Ach so. Ah!
Und das sind jetzt verschiedene Muster. [Sally bejaht]
Aaaah!
SALLY: Cool, oder?
AARON: Was es alles gibt.
SALLY: Kann man Resteverwertung machen.
AARON: Ja, gut.
So viel, wie du backst und kochst: Warum bist du denn nicht…
SALLY: Ich nasche nicht.
AARON: Nein? Okay.
SALLY: Wolltest du das fragen?
AARON: Ja, naja. Du bist ja top in Form.
Und ich backe und koche nicht die ganze Zeit
und bin ein kleines Schweinchen.
SALLY: Wenn man viel backt,
dann hat man keine Lust mehr auf das Essen.
Dann warten wir jetzt, bis die Tarte gebacken ist.
Dann geht’s weiter.
AARON: Wie lange dauert das?
SALLY: 30 Minuten.
Dann können wir später noch die Mascarpone-Creme anrühren.
AARON: Da kommt noch etwas drauf?
SALLY: Ja. [Lacht]
AARON: Oh, ich dachte, wir sind fertig.
SALLY: Oh, heute voll das komplizierte Rezept.
AARON: Auch schon wieder so ein Rutschschutz. [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Das ist ein Stabilizer. Der stabilisiert.
AARON: Wirklich? Krass!
SALLY: Also die Tarte ist fertig gebacken, abgekühlt
und ich habe sie in den Kühlschrank gestellt.
Jetzt kommt oben eine Mascarpone-Creme drauf.
Es ist ja eine Tiramisu-Tarte. Deswegen muss schon Mascarpone sein.
Dafür haben wir jetzt schon Zutaten, nämlich
50 Puderzucker, 250 g Mascarpone, 250 g Sahne
und San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
Wer möchte, kann auch Amaretto dazugeben, muss aber nicht, okay?
AARON: Ist es das Gleiche, was du hast?
SALLY: Genau, das ist das hier, nur einmal umgefüllt.
AARON: Und wir machen alles rein?
SALLY: Erst einmal nur die Mascarpone.
AARON: Ja, aber von der machen wir alles rein?
SALLY: Genau, den Puderzucker noch dazu.
AARON: Ich verwende heute so viele Sachen, wo ich weiß,
dass es sie gibt, aber keine Ahnung habe, wie sie schmecken.
SALLY: Noch nie Mascarpone probiert?
AARON: So schmeckt es jetzt nicht so gut.
SALLY: Nein, es ist so ein Frischkäse. Es heißt auch „der“ Mascarpone.
Ich vergesse es immer – DER Mascarpone.
AARON: Nicht schlimm. Und noch Mehl rein.
SALLY: Puderzucker.
AARON: Meine ich ja.
SALLY: Dann kurz rühren, bis es sich verbunden hat.
AARON: Stufe 1? [Sally bejaht]
[Handrührgerät]
SALLY: Putzt du später auch das Studio? Das gehört mit zum Praktikum.
Jeder Tag wird mit einem Wischmopp beendet.
AARON: Wirklich?
SALLY: Am Ende des Arbeitstages muss die Küche
und der Boden sauber sein und alle Zutaten verräumt,
dass sie nicht schlecht werden.
AARON: Ja, das ist wichtig. [Sally stimmt zu]
Natürlich mache ich das!
SALLY: Dann kriegst du auch einen Ausbildungsschein, okay?
Dann kannst du langsam die Sahne dazu gießen
- schön langsam.
AARON: Warum langsam?
SALLY: Damit es sich gut mit dem Mascarpone verbindet.
[Musik]
Genau. Du musst gucken, dass sich da keine Klumpen bilden.
[Handrührgerät]
Dann nehmen wir 4,5 TL San-apart dazu.
AARON: Was ist das?
SALLY: San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
AARON: Ich dachte, es wird von allein steif.
SALLY: 2, 3… wird sie auch, aber so bleibt sie länger steif.
Warte, ich brauche noch einen 1/2 TL – so!
AARON: Wie viel jetzt?
SALLY: 4,5 gestrichene TL – genau.
AARON: 1, 2…
SALLY: Ich finde, man sieht schon…
Guck mal, bei mir sieht es schon cremiger aus; bei dir auch.
Nimm ruhig alles vom Rand mit.
AARON: Ah, ich weiß, was du meinst.
SALLY: Schön! Wird dickflüssiger, gell? [Aaron bejaht]
Wenn man zu lange rührt, dann… ist kaputt!
AARON: Ja? [Sally bejaht]
AARON: Oh, sagst du mir, wann ich aufhören muss?
SALLY: Jetzt guckst du einmal. Das läuft noch ein bisschen.
Läuft es noch? Dann noch ein bisschen.
Perfekt!
AARON: Bei mir läuft es auch – doch!
Läuft noch, oder? [Sally stimmt zu]
Weitermachen oder aufhören?
SALLY: Noch ein bisschen weiter.
[Musik]
AARON: Oh, das ist so geil.
Das schmeckt wie die gute, die man auf den Kuchen drauf macht.
Es gibt ja jetzt in den Supermärkten nur noch diese Öko-Variante,
wo kein Zucker drin ist, wo du denkst:
Was ist denn das für eine Ka**e. [Sally stimmt zu]
Und da – Ooooooooohhhh!
SALLY: Die ist gut, gell?
AARON: Jaaa! Oooohhh! Und die Schlagsahne – oooohhhhh! Ohhhh!
SALLY: Und jetzt kannst du das Ganze in den Spritzbeutel einfüllen.
[Sally lacht]
AARON: Das beste Leben!
Jetzt kann ich meine Diät auch vergessen.
SALLY: Hier hast du noch zwei.
AARON: Mmh! Beste!
So eine gute Schlagsahne hatte ich schon lange nicht mehr.
SALLY: Guck mal, das ist eine Spritzbeuteleinfüllhilfe.
AARON: Wofür es alles Hilfen gibt.
SALLY: Spritzbeutelständer.
[Beide lachen]
AARON: Ah, beste Leben! [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Jetzt weißt du, was mit Murat passiert ist, oder? [Aaron bejaht]
Die letzten 13 Jahre…
AARON: Aber das ist wirklich – ey…
SALLY: Dafür hat er sich aber gut gehalten.
AARON: Ansichtssache. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: 30 kg in 10 Jahren? Ja…
AARON: Und du?
SALLY: Ich? 10 kg.
AARON: Wirklich? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Aber ich war damals…
AARON: Du bist auch Mama.
SALLY: Ja, eben. Ich bin auch Mama. Alles okay.
AARON: Ich habe jetzt gar nicht aufgepasst, weil ich gerade…
Aber du hast mir gesagt, da gibt’s das und dann mache ich das rein.
SALLY: Genau, das schneiden wir vorher noch ab.
AARON: Warum ist es hier schief?
SALLY: Schief?
AARON: Ich habe vorhin so gekichert beim Spritzbeutel.
Ich habe Angst, dass ich hier was falsch mache.
Von wegen, hoffentlich ist er so dumm.
SALLY: Jetzt den Zipfel umdrehen, dass nichts ausläuft.
AARON: Wie umdrehen?
SALLY: Einfach einmal so umknicken.
AARON: Ach so, okay. Das ergibt Sinn.
SALLY: Oben umstülpen.
Ja, und da kannst du einfüllen, ohne dass du es halten musst.
Das ist schon praktisch.
AARON: Jetzt nehme ich hier wieder diesen Löffel und gebe es rein?
SALLY: Genau. Weil du beide Hände frei hast,
kannst du die Schüssel hochnehmen.
AARON: Ich kann aber auch so machen. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Voll der Konditor. [Aaron stimmt zu]
AARON: Mit den ganzen Hilfen, die es hier gibt,
kann das ja auch jeder.
SALLY: Gell? Kochen und Backen ist einfach.
AARON: Naja.
SALLY: Schön. Jetzt den Beutel so zusammendrehen.
Genau, so hoch und dann hier das Ende zusammen.
AARON: Aber ich will… Kannst du das mal hier halten?
Ich muss es doch runterdrücken, oder?
SALLY: Ja, drücke es weiter runter.
AARON: Ich will natürlich mit Gefühl.
Okay, und jetzt ein bisschen drehen. Halte fest!
Wie so ein Handtuch und jetzt haben wir’s.
SALLY: Ja?
AARON: Und jetzt?
SALLY: Sehr gut. Dann kannst du es jetzt ablegen.
Man kann es auch da drin schön ablegen, so mit der Spitze.
[Sally lacht]
AARON: Oh, beste!
SALLY: So, immer gleich weg. Dann haben wir Platz.
AARON: Ja, der Arbeitsplatz muss aufgeräumt sein. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Regel Nummer 1: Alles muss immer gleich weg. [Aaron bejaht]
AARON: Das ist gesund, mit gesunder Milch!
SALLY: Gut.
AARON: Hast du mal probiert?
Das würde ich mal am liebsten mit…
Das war meine? [Sally bejaht]
Nein!
SALLY: Doch, die sieht gut aus!
AARON: Wirklich?
Das war deine? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Jetzt hältst du den Spritzbeutel so aufrecht.
Die Hand drückt die Creme raus. Bist du Rechts- oder Linkshänder?
AARON: Rechts. Und jetzt einfach alles voll machen?
[Musik]
SALLY: Sieht gut aus.
AARON: Ich habe aber zu wenig.
SALLY: Ja, mach ein bisschen größere Tupfer.
AARON: Okay.
SALLY: Also wenn du keine Häufchen, sondern Tupfer willst,
musst du… [lacht] senkrecht draufspritzen.
AARON: Ich mach‘ das schon!
Wie mit Bauschaum. [Sally stimmt zu]
Hallo.
SALLY: Oh, ich habe auf den Boden gekleckert.
Willst du probieren?
ELA: Ja, da.
SALLY: Ich habe jetzt aus Versehen voll den Klecks drauf gemacht.
AARON: Toll!
SALLY: Toll! Die ganze Optik zerstört. Magst du probieren?
Soll ich machen?
AARON: Sch**ß auf Diabetes. [Sally lacht]
ELA UND AARON: Mmh!
AARON: Welcher sieht denn hübscher aus, Ela?
SALLY: Welcher ist hübscher?
Beide schön, oder? Aww, so ein diplomatisches Kind!
AARON: Sie hat auf beide gezeigt.
Du hast auf meinen gezeigt, oder?
Du hast auf die gezeigt.
ELA: Auf diesen und auf diesen.
SALLY: Aww, süße Maus!
So, dann können wir jetzt eigentlich…
SALLY: Ja, den nimmt der Aaron mit für zu Hause.
AARON: Iss ruhig!
SALLY: Guck mal, jetzt haben wir Kakao
- ist ja eine Tiramisu-Tarte.
So. Ich habe Reis in diesem Sieb drin.
AARON: Was hast du da drin?
SALLY: Trockenen Reis, damit nicht so viel Kakao auf einmal rauskommt;
dass es ein bisschen dosiert herauskommt.
AARON: Stimmt, da ist wirklich Reis drin.
Wie viel muss denn da drauf?
SALLY: So viel, wie du willst.
AARON: Ich bin nicht so ein Fan,
weil ich früher in meinem Backshop immer,
wenn die Schokobrötchen ein bisschen brauner wurden,
entweder viel Glasur oder Puderzucker draufgemacht habe.
Dann kennst du es: Wenn du zu viel Puderzucker reinmachst und dabei
einatmest, dann kommt dir… [Geräusche der Erstickung]
Das haben regelmäßig mehrere Kunden bei mir…
SALLY: Oh.
Dann sind wir fertig und lösen die Tarte heraus.
Es ist ja ein Hebeboden darunter.
Dann richten wir es an; Sarah darf Bilder machen für die App.
AARON: So, jetzt hier so hoch.
SALLY: Jetzt von unten mit der Hand – genau.
AARON: So?
SALLY: Dann da rüber.
AARON: Dann da rüber.
SALLY: Dann darfst du dir eine Tortenplatte
zum Präsentieren aussuchen.
AARON: Mit dem Silbernen da oben.
SALLY: Die?
AARON: Ja, bitte.
SALLY: Okay, kriegst du.
AARON: Vielen Dank! Welche möchtest du?
SALLY: Ich nehme diese.
Schön, dass er meinen Tortendrehteller als Tortenständer…
AARON: Ist es nicht…?
SALLY: … als Dekora… Doch, kannst du auch machen.
AARON: Mache ich die Torte da jetzt so rüber oder das Ding mit drauf?
SALLY: Guck mal!
AARON: Oder lasse ich das so rüber sliden? [Sally bejaht]
Und du bist jetzt zum Abwaschen gekommen?
SALLY: Ja, sie ist die Spülhilfe.
Da haben wir noch einen Boden drunter.
AARON: Mir wird voll schnell schwindelig.
Allein nur vom Zugucken vom Tellerdrehen ist mir schwindelig geworden.
SALLY: Ich kann das auch nicht.
AARON: Ich fahre sogar in einer Tiefgarage nur einen Kreis runter
und mir ist schlecht.
SALLY: Echt? [Aaron bejaht]
AARON: Ich halte den Rekord bei Galileo:
Am meisten brechen bei einem Beitrag.
Wir haben eine Achterbahn getestet
und ich habe die Dispo nicht gelesen. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Perfekt.
ELA: Kann mir jemand bitte den Puderzucker reichen?
SALLY: Die Platte darunter nehmen wir noch weg.
AARON: Aber selbstverständlich! Hier ist der Puderzucker.
Warte, ich räume ihn hier rüber.
Und jetzt brauchst du einen Keks, oder?
Brauchst du einen Keks?
SALLY: Ich lasse ihn drunter.
AARON: Ja?
[Musik]
SALLY: Ela, jetzt geht’s ans Tarte-Verkosten.
Welche Tarte willst du probieren?
Also diese ist mit Kaffee und diese ist mit Schokolade.
ELA: Beide!
AARON: Darf ich meine jetzt anschneiden?
SALLY: Ja. Probiere lieber die von Aaron, okay?
AARON: Die ist mit Schoki.
SALLY: Da ist nämlich kein Kaffee drin.
ELA: Ist das für die Erwachsenen?
AARON UND SALLY: Ja genau.
SALLY: Die ist für Erwachsene.
ELA: Deswegen schmeckt sie so komisch.
AARON: Ja, und diese ist für Kinder.
SALLY: [Lacht] Sie hat nämlich schon probiert und hat gesagt,
es schmeckt komisch wegen dem Kaffee.
AARON: Du machst den ersten Stich. Ich bin so gespannt.
SALLY: Mmh! Finde ich mit Kaffee voll gut!
AARON: Mmh! Schmeckt mit Schoki voll gut – richtig gut, richtig gut!
Oh, voll der Magier am Herd.
SALLY: Ich probiere deine auch.
Magst du mit Kaffee probieren oder nicht?
AARON: Ich probiere mal, aber ich mag wirklich absolut…
Nein, mir ist der Kaffeegeschmack zu doll.
SALLY: Weißt du, was da so gut ist? Die Tonka Bohne - dieses Aroma!
AARON: Ja?
SALLY: Das passt so gut zur Schokolade.
Also du hast eine schöne Tonka-Bohnen-Schokoladen-Tarte gemacht.
AARON: Für die Kinder!
SALLY: Ja. Und ich habe für die Erwachsenen eine Kaffee-Tarte gemacht.
Und, Ela, kann der Aaron gut backen? [Ela bejaht]
Ja?
AARON: Ela, welche schmeckt den besser:
Für die Kinder oder für die Erwachsenen?
ELA: Beide.
AARON: So diplomatisch.
SALLY: Die Ela ist immer so diplomatisch.
Du darfst ruhig ehrlich sagen. Ich bin auch nicht sauer oder so.
Ich bin auch nicht traurig, wenn dir meine nicht schmeckt.
Du kannst ruhig sagen, dass dir die mit Kaffee nicht geschmeckt hat.
Hmm?
AARON: Beides.
SALLY: Man darf seine ehrliche Meinung sagen.
Man muss ja niemanden damit verletzten.
AARON: [Sehr leise] Mega gut!
ELA: Ja, das hier hat ein bisschen komisch geschmeckt,
das andere schmeckt halt auch so…
Das hat ein bisschen komisch geschmeckt wegen dem Kaffee,
sonst ist alles lecker!
[Awwww]
AARON: [Mit nachgeahmter Stimme] Eigentlich alles gut,
nur der Kaffee…
SALLY: Du süße Maus!
Sehr gut. Ich muss gleich noch etwas holen.
Ich habe nämlich noch etwas für den Aaron.
Erfahrt ihr gleich
– meine Haarsträhne ist einmal komplett um mein Kopf gewickelt.
Ich muss noch kurz etwas holen, denn…
AARON: Ich schneide den für alle hier auf.
SALLY: Er hat es ja heute echt gut gemacht, muss ich schon sagen.
Ich bin echt stolz auf dich.
AARON: Danke, ich auch auf mich, aber ich werde es nie wieder machen.
SALLY: Ach komm!
AARON: Voll anstrengend!
SALLY: Es hat doch Spaß gemacht.
AARON: Nein! Dein Job – wer denkt, das ist Pillepalle…
ist so anstrengend!
SALLY: Aber wir haben doch heute nur zwei Rezepte gemacht.
AARON: Anstrengend.
SALLY: Ich hole schnell etwas. Ich guck einmal, ob es fertig ist.
AARON: Marvin, möchtest du ein bisschen Schoki?
MARVIN: Ich bin noch mit der Pizza am Gange.
SALLY: Ich meine, wenn man schon einmal ein Praktikum bei mir macht,
dann bekommt man natürlich auch eine Urkunde,
wie bei den Bundesjugendspielen.
Es ist jetzt keine Note oder so,
aber wie bei den Bundesjugendspielen „Teilnahme erfolgreich“.
Von daher – hat er echt gut gemacht!
Gab es bei euch damals die Bundesjugendspiele?
AARON: Ja.
SALLY: Und, wie war es so bei dir?
AARON: Wir hatten es zweimal und ich war zweimal verletzt.
SALLY: War immer so erfolgreiche Teilnahme?
AARON: Nein, ich bin früher sportlich gewesen, immer noch…
SALLY: Du kriegst heute nämlich eine Urkunde
für dein erfolgreich abgeschlossenes Praktikum:
1x1 des Backens,
1x1 des Kochens,
1x1 des Zwiebelschneidens,
Handrührgerätführerschein – hast du!
Gesunder Pausensnack für Kinder – muss Ela noch beurteilen:
Hat dein Pausensnack geschmeckt? Hat er es gut gemacht?
War es gesund?
Okay
Und Auskratzen von Schüsseln,
weil du es schon ganz eigenständig ausgekratzt hast.
AARON: Ja. Und immer Naschi Naschi.
Unterschreibst du das jetzt auch noch?
SALLY: Na klar – unterschreibe ich dir noch!
AARON: Wer braucht die IHK?
SALLY: So.
AARON: Geil!
SALLY: Dann rahmen wir es jetzt gleich ein und dann…
AARON: Dann kommt es ins Büro.
SALLY: Ja. Guck mal!
So, komm, wir rutschen dich mal mit deiner Torte rüber.
Also, Herr Troschke!
AARON: Oh, Danke schön!
SALLY: Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
AARON: Vielen Dank. Geil, da freue ich mich!
Hast du nicht!
SALLY: Einmal bitte für die Presse.
Einmal bitte ein Foto für die Presse.
[Fotoapparat]
[Musik]
Tarte geglückt.
Pizza haben wir auch noch in einem anderen Video gebacken.
Schaut es euch gern an.
Würdest du die Tarte nachbacken?
AARON: Ich würde sie essen und ich finde sie gut,
aber es war echt anstrengend.
Kochen und Backen ist anstrengend.
Ich bin froh, dass ich nur Klamauk mache.
SALLY: Also, viel Spaß beim Nachbacken. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
BEIDE: Tschüss!
[Musik]
ELA: Kann es sein, dass du faul bist?
AARON: Ja. [Lacht]
Ich esse gern und koche nicht gern.
SALLY: Ja, Ela. Was blüht ihm jetzt noch?
Jetzt haben wir 2 Video gedreht: gekocht und gebacken.
Jetzt wird noch aufgewischt, geputzt, Küche einsortiert,
Lebensmittel versorgen, d.h., ans Team verteilen,
alle Lebensmittel lebensmittelgerecht verpacken.
Ja, dann noch Kinderbetreuung, Nachhilfe und Samira hat noch Klavier.
AARON: Ooooooh!
SALLY: Und wir müssen noch für den Fernsehgarten packen.
Also wir haben noch ein bisschen was vor.
AARON: Ja. Weiter geht’s.
ELA: und es ist eine Giraffe geworden [Aaron stimmt zu]
SALLY: So, los Ela. Komm!
[Musik]